happy wednesday everyone
except you steve in pottstown
pennsylvania i can see what you're doing
and it's sickening at least don't do it
in front of me and put your poodle in
the other room
so you want to see how powerful the
media industrial complex is watch how
they can create something out of nothing
and they get everyone from politicians
to reporters to washed up celebrities by
buying into it blindly
david david copperfield has nothing on
them i refer to the parental rights bill
in florida even righty websites call it
controversial even though the bill is
only controversial because the media
lied about it the bill bans instruction
of sexual orientation and gender
identity in kindergarten through third
grade the only part i found
controversial is the third grade part
how about teachers of any grade staying
out of your kids private life you power
hungry control freaks
now like my extra nipples the bill seems
pretty benign to me
last thing i want to talk to a
kindergartner about is gender the second
to last thing i want to do is talk to a
kindergartner
and if anyone tried to teach me that
stuff when i was that age it would screw
me up i was still in the process of
figuring out the anatomy of ken and not
the doll the bus driver
but
but if this bill upsets you that's on
you you're weird
seriously are you really that passionate
about kids in kindergarten learning this
stuff that spells creepy with a capital
k or maybe it says one big virtue signal
ratcheted up by your own intellectual
laziness see if anyone cared to read the
bill the outrage would die and they'd
have to let go of the lie so the media
couldn't read it and as long as they
don't they can say it bans the word gay
it's the media's version of adjusting
with smallet hoax and frankly making
assumptions about something you haven't
read isn't just dumb it could be
dangerous
all righty sir i didn't get a chance to
read your chart just yet but i did hear
someone in the hallway say we have to
remove your appendix and your testicles
so let's get those pants off okay whoa
whoa whoa wait a minute there's no way
this chart could say that maybe you
should read it i watch don lemon tonight
okay i think i know what i'm doing wait
and what does he know about this well we
may be doctors but he's on tv grow up
hmm you do raise a good point i guess
i'll prep the patient now for surgery
so you've seen don't say gay in the
headlines because the media won they
pushed the lie knowing their peers were
too lazy to check it they were right and
what happens you create a mental illness
caused by fake news when adults redefine
hysteria as entertainment
we're going to have a great night
tonight and for you people in florida
we're going to have a gay night
wow how edgy chanting gay in front of a
live audience filled with nothing but
ultra liberal hollywood celebs what are
you gonna do next feed a christian to
simba and mufasa how about a dance
number about raising the minimum wage so
it turns out reading scripts isn't the
only time fiction comes out of actors
mouths they're so pleased with
themselves like driving a prius to their
private jet
but that's what happens in a delusion
you think you're showing the world
you're the smart one when you're
anything but
look at disney which claims governor ron
desantis wants to erase gay kids an odd
position from a company whose cruises
actually go to countries where
homosexuality is indeed erased where
being gay is actually banned i guess
it's just cheaper to virtue signal than
act on your principles virtue signaling
is the only thing that's free at disney
the magic and magic kingdom is how they
make 10 disappear in exchange for
fountain soda
then there's actor ron perlman who used
to think for himself but now he's let
twitter run his brain
apparently that's all he reads and so
here he is going off on the bill
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words in a sentence
spoken by a political leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't
say you
nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you piece
oh it gets so hot when he gets so
bothered
so clearly that is not a healthy man
that's someone infected with a mind
virus that escaped from a disney lab in
anaheim and spread by the mainstream
media but he too was also a victim duped
by a fiction created purely to suck
people like him into a maelstrom of rage
and conflict he's what the media wants
the more pearlman's you get the more
money you make you addict someone to
rage and he's gonna need another fix
every day and with useful idiots like
him disney won't need goofy
maybe it will offset the money they lose
on woke movies
poor pearlman he used to be in sons of
anarchy now he's just son of sam a guy
hearing untruths from his dog pluto and
lost the ability to interpret what's
real
all he understands now is free publicity
now in case he's watching and i doubt it
or he wouldn't have fallen for this crap
because this show is like rehab for
people hooked on misinformation the bill
bans classroom instruction on sexual
orientation and gender identity with
children in third grade or younger or
quote in a manner that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in accordance
with state standards that's it the bill
doesn't ban the word gay nor does it ban
casual discussions of topics relating to
sexual orientation or gender
and teachers under this bill they can't
teach about being straight either
and that's the only group with no
parades
periods welcome tonight's guest she's
got more grit than a sandpaper factory
co-host of the five judge jeanine pirro
just like your deadbeat dad he left the
house and he's never coming back former
gop congressman and fox news contributor
jason chavez
and she's been on more thin ice than
brian boytano fox news contributor kat
tim
[Applause]
and his pocket square is a picnic
blanket my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television champion
oh i'm hyperventilating that's a quick
way to get high judge you can't arrest
me for that
i'll try you will are you
hyperventilating to get buzzed let me
measure your brain cells you'll say and
then you'll throw me in the clink
and then you'll cuff me and god oh who
knows what'll happen oh my god my brain
goes into dark places judge has
disneyland become the playground for
satan
well
you know the disappointing part of it
now is like to me disneyland is a place
you take your kids you take your
grandkids but now they can't say ladies
and gentlemen they can't say boys and
girls they have to say dreamers and by
the way what is california the woken
people in california how dare they
impose their concepts or their ideas on
florida which overwhelmingly supports
this bill that and not for one second
does it say don't say gay and i got to
tell you i used to love sons of anarchy
ron perlman just lost me i can't stand
you you know why you're stupid that's
stupid you go out there i don't care how
big you are to go out there and say
you're a piece of nazi pizza
you didn't even read the stupid bill
you're stupid i love it you swore the
judge swore all that i did yeah you did
you said
she quoted she quoted
yeah i mean
you're a piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh i'm not gonna sleep tonight
jason didn't
disney i think thought that they could
they could use their muscle on desantis
and he went ahead and signed the bill
anyway it's kind of ballsy on his part
well actually it's not he's just doing
the right thing bronte said it's a
simple thing
and you know what to suggest that you
know t where are the teachers in all
this yeah
come on you're a pervert if you think
that
teaching a second grader about gender
identity
is the right way to go and i'd love to
hear them make the counter argument that
they should be informing a second grader
it's here's spot here's another spot
here's spot on spot no that's not the
way i was thought you know the uh that
is i think why the don't say gay thing
was kind of their version of defund the
police except to fund the police was
actually said but they were doing that
to hang on around the republicans neck
because they didn't want to argue with
the bill because it's hard it's a hard
bill to argue against uh there's it's
kind of reasonable tyrus you have
children yeah and uh the idea of a
stranger that went to school for four
years to teach
arithmetic or english to talk to my
children about sexuality or any other
moral
dilemma hell no it's about the parents
you've decided what you talk about in
your household and it's very simple if
my household
was affected in terms of we had a family
member who was transgender or we had a
situation that directly affected my
child and i want then we would discuss
it but
when they get older just like you used
to wait to talk about birds and the bees
till you were like 14 and 15 your dad
are in my case a
occasional boyfriend would come by and
be like hey
tyrus right yes sir and let's talk about
the bro i'll wait so but it was the
parents choice this law should never
have even been put into effect but
because
we are allowing this small group and
when you say the people of california
it's not
it was like three ceos and some woke
people who have their own issues they're
trying to push their thing and what
we're seeing is what we saw with rogan
what we're seeing with spotify we're
seeing with other companies netflix when
you stand up to them they go away
because they actually have no foundation
and no following there's not a million
people standing outside disney going
change it it's this group and if disney
had anything if right now six flags
knott's berry farm i would start running
commercials boys and girls ladies and
gentlemen come on in bring your kids
bring your kids bring your family
and give an alternative so you want to
go there and put that stuff out there
find another place with roller coasters
and
rats and ducks with speech impediments
to hang out with yes have you ever been
to disneyland or disney world you don't
seem like an amusement park person
it's fine yeah
you find amusement and like i always
feel that you can amuse yourself with
your brain i don't need to go on space
mountain when there's so much space
inside here
no
i guess
did i read the bill for nothing
okay well to be perfectly clear i am a
pervert i still don't want to talk to
kids about sex right i don't know why
you would but there are two words in the
bill that concern me that always do
which is state standards
those are the ones i'm always like okay
because that's not really the parents
then that's the state deciding
and i don't i'm always like concerned
about anything that makes a rule for a
whole state full of kids because all
kids are individuals they have different
needs and we'll have it's all vague
we'll have to see how it ends up working
out in practice because those state
standards are never
uh you know they never actually say
anything but yeah the bill doesn't say
gay it says sexual orientation so i know
all these people are upset like if a guy
has a picture with his husband on his
desk is that going to make you know
you'd only get in trouble i would think
is if you you know if also people had
pictures with their wives who were got
because straight is also a sexual
orientation i believe
um so you know we'll have to see how it
shakes out but i just think in general
less government in the schools more
options
for parents yes
well put all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else